Hey Team it’s Charlie thanks to everyone
who submitted questions for this week’s
Q&A.
I saw a lot of you were wondering the same
thing about secret identities and people coming
back for the finale.
I also have some announcements about next
week I’ll make at the end of the video just
because some new stuff is coming next week.
I’m also going to start including more of
that in the video descriptions below.
So be sure to check there.
This episode was the last of the leaked scripts
too, so I think we’ll be able to have a
little more fun talking about what we think
is going to happen even though there were
still a few leaked pictures from the finale.
Speaking of which Time Heist, careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven’t
seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay here we go
Question 1 - Jack Marriot asks when is The
Doctor going to start talking about where
his face came from again?
It’s possible they could wait till the last
couple of episodes.
I think there’s two things going on here.
I think it’s a clever way to reference Capaldi’s
other characters from Doctor Who and Torchwood
and I think it’s going to tie in with the
finale.
Because of the way these episodes are mostly
one-offs and don’t really carry over too
much, I’m thinking more and more that they’ll
wait till the end of the season to directly
address it.
Use a giant chunk of an episode to talk about
it.
He did make the joke about coming out looking
like a Magician, so at least he’s referencing
himself.
I think we’ll see more of that in the one-off
episodes.
Him just making fun of himself.
But I don’t know that’s necessarily part
of the overarching plot.
I think it’s just the writers being cheeky.
Question 2 - Blue Headphones asks At the end
when the Doctor jokes about the date, do you
think the Doctor and Danny will compete over
Clara?
I really hope not, I do think they’ll address
it next week in Episode 6.
It looks like Clara is as tired as I am.
Right now she’s burning the candle at both
ends, spending all the extra time with The
Doctor and returning to her normal life as
if no time has passed at all.
Theoretically, if a companion wanted to.
They could stay with the Doctor their entire
life.
So even though they always return to the point
they left off, they still age normally.
Meaning that unless Clara is sleeping on the
TARDIS, she’s probably not sleeping much
at all.
I liked the Doctor’s joke about calories
consumed on the TARDIS, it’s the same thing
with sleep.
Question 3 - wofllover asks do you think the
other characters Capaldi has played on Doctor
Who and Torchwood were clones?
I don’t, but back when Russell Davies was
still doing Torchwood and he cast Capaldi
he came up with a clever explanation.
I don’t think he ever said what it was,
but he did plan to address it.
Obviously Moffat has since cast him as The
Doctor, negating whatever Davies story would
have been but I’m sure he also has his own
explanation.
In Deep Breath he said he felt like he was
trying to tell himself something.
I don’t think those other faces will be
critical to that, I think the explanation
will be less complex.
But for fans of Torchwood and the big whovians
I think Moffat’s explanation will allow
room for tin foil hat theories.
A lot of times when fans confront Moffat with
big questions about plot holes his answers
make it sound like he wants there to be multiple
interpretations.
I do think we’ll learn what The Doctor’s
face means by the finale, but I think it will
satisfy everyone’s questions.
Think about it this way, there are still people
debating how many new regnerations The Doctor
was given in the christmas special.
And Moffat has never gone on record stating
a number.
Question 4 - Joe Kerr asks do you think we’ll
see River Song anytime soon?
I’m kind of hoping we don’t but not because
I hate her or anything.
What I’d really like to see is a big twist
in the finale that doesn’t completely depend
on something from a previous series.
I really like the idea of them doing something
fresh.
Like Missy not having anything to do with
River.
Just being someone totally new.
The woman in the shop with the Doctor’s
phone number is a good example.
I’d be a little disappointed if it was River
this whole time.
I feel like with the exception of new people
we’ll meet between now and the finale.
We’ve already met all the people that will
be critical to the big arcs in series 8.
Even if there’s a big Moffat Loop at the
end.
I still like the idea that someone could start
watching the show for the first time this
year with Deep Breath, watch only the Series
8 episodes and be able to understand who all
the characters are and the big twist in the
finale.
That just feels like a much cleaner execution
from a storytelling perspective.
It feels like something the BBC would be happier
with from an audience development standpoint
too.
It would be too daunting to new viewers if
they had to do a mountain of homework just
to understand what’s going on.
Question 5 - David Rice asks what do you think
happened to all the regular people in the
bank when the solar storm destroyed the planet?
Part of me wants to think they were all killed,
or at least the ones not deep inside the earth.
The strange thing is if they were in the far
future and had all that cool security technology,
would they also be able to forecast solar
weather.
It seemed like the Solar Storm was a big surprise,
but if they had such advanced tech, why didn’t
they know it was going to happen?
Big events like that still take a while to
happen, it’s not instantaneous.
So we’ll just call that a plot hole.
Question 6 - Orlando asks Do you think that
Psi and Saibra will have anything to do with
the finale?
The finale talks about old friends and old
enemies manouvering around The Doctor, so
it’s possible.
When I think about Saibra’s powers, they
feel a lot like the Tesselecta, with the ability
to mimick other people and that was the solution
to the series 6 plot.
So part of me feels like they wouldn’t use
that again.
I believe that the patternoster gang is rumored
to be back and the UNIT characters, but aside
from them I haven’t seen any news about
other friendly characters.
Question 7 - Sarah Walden asks Do you think
they’d kill Clara off if she leaves this
year? or Go more Amy and Rory with it?
I don’t think it would grotesque or anything.
I guess I am expecting an Amy Rory ending.
Not the exact same thing.
But I feel like she’d pay a big price and
still get a happy ending with Danny Pink.
It feels like the show is pushing her towards
Danny Pink and wants us to feel like it’s
a good thing.
Regardless of what might happen to him in
the finale.
I think he’s a good character.
It is moffat, so I think she won’t walk
away completely intact.
I don’t think it will be straight up Dalek
Oswin, but something close.
That’s only if she does go, there is a small
chance she’ll stay on.
But it feels like the show is preparing us
for her to leave.
Mostly with all this Danny Pink romance stuff.
Question 8 - Micki Chiba asks do you think
lady karabraxos is Romana?
I think she was a completely new character.
That’s what the BBC called her.
A new villain.
It’s possible she could come back as a clone
but I’m thinking more and more with each
episode, that none of the characters is secretly
someone from classic who.
Question 9 - fg pinkey asks What was Clara’s
reward for robbing the bank?
Good question, I think it was just the date.
As the Doctor called it.
Getting the thrill of robbing the richest
bank in the Universe.
The doctor made that comment that he didn’t
know what his reward was and I think his also
might have been tied to that idea of the date.
Like he was rewarded with the thrill of seeing
Clara get a thrill.
Even though they did that big speech in Deep
Breath about the doctor no longer seeking
approval of others through his appearance.
It still feels like he wants approval from
Clara if he’s still trying to impress her.
Question 10 - ttam asks What is the giveaway
for?
The giveaways are typically $20 amazon gift
cards.
The exception is my weekly Game of Thrones
giveaway.
That’s a book giveaway.
In general I just do giveaways as a way to
say thank you to all my subscribers, that’s
pretty much it.
This year I am planning on adding some google
hangouts as rewards for giveaways and stuff
like that so once I figure it out I’ll make
an announcement.
But thank you so much everyone for submitting
questions.
These are always a lot of fun to do.
Congrats to lazermonkey, you’re this weeks
giveaway winner.
You win a $20 amazon gift card.
I’ll be reaching out to you on your channel
for details.
So be sure to check your inbox.
Because I’m catching up on sleep I’m a
little behind on Walking Dead and Game of
Thrones, so I’ll get those videos out next.
But next week Gotham and Agents of SHIELD
start season 2.
For UK people, Gotham is on Channel 5 and
Agents of SHIELD is on Channel 4.
I’ve already done some preview videos for
those so I’ll add links in the description
to help you get ready.
Right now click here to learn all about the
christmas special this year and click here
for my episode 5 review.
Thanks for watching, everybody high five and
we’ll meet tomorrow night to talk about
Gotham!